we are at crossroads that's quite clear
from all your future perspectives we are
again at crossroads but how much faith
and why can we have in the present
ruling class the people who are now out
our politicians our bankers are we
colonists our the media Tigers listen
they are the changemakers right so
listen and how much can we expect from
them / office you are in your book how
to run the world quite optimistic i may
say when it comes down to humanitarians
you talk about mega diplomacy as a way
out so give her some hope well actually
in the spirit of what ori was saying
that book is extraordinarily pessimistic
about global structures grantsolutions
it's it's the anti global governance
book about global governance it's the
book about the triumph of the local over
the global so it's exactly in the spirit
of what Rory was saying and I find that
you know in our first comments we were
quite either or i think that would to
sort of sum it up none of us wanted to
take a position and say that a
technological age is definitely going to
be good or bad and i think that that's
healthy we nuclear web / can heat homes
or can destroy nations and we know that
both potentials still exist and we have
to be careful not to conflate
technologies however I actually never
used the word internet even once in in
my opening comments at all and that
might have been intentional or otherwise
but most people in the world don't have
access to the internet most people in
the world are starting to get mobile
phones which is but not necessarily the
internet this technological diffusion
that's happening is itself not about
perfectionism right it's just about
possibility it's about individual
empowerment and I think this gets to
your question empowerment with knowledge
the ability to be a correction on
authority a correction on elite
authority and this is where the Arab
Spring is interesting of course you know
currently right now as it stands the
Egyptian government has not you know is
no less hierarchical and you know it
does not look like Wikipedia it is not
networks have not replaced the
hierarchical structure of that
government that doesn't mean that
that networks are not useful tools and
challenging hierarchies and in reframing
them and in being this corrective on
power and those networks are comprised
of those individuals who have
experienced a certain kind of
empowerment not purely through
technology but various forms of
diffusion of knowledge and I think
that's extremely important for us to
appreciate that now to the political we
haven't I haven't heard all day I think
the the word that that defines really
one of the most secular profound ships
that we're experiencing all of the world
that is devolution and devolution is
something that is not necessarily rooted
in in technological change it's about
demographics it's about urbanization
it's about finance but it's it's
certainly about politics it's happening
in democracies and a non democracies
it's hard to think of a country in the
world that isn't experiencing in some
way this fragmentation of ironclad
central authority in some way shape or
form particularly through the rise of
cities the power of Mayors the desire of
individuals to control their own local
politics and budgets and and and usage
of resource rents and revenues and so
forth and evolution is extraordinarily
important and it redefines the
geographic locus of authority there are
people whether it's in California or in
Swiss con tones or an Afghan provinces
most certainly all of India right which
we can you know the world's largest
democracy is not really run in New Delhi
its run in 25 different state capitals
the states or in many profound
day-to-day and otherwise ways more
powerful than their central government
this this devolution is a huge
opportunity to bring the politics down
to a scale that is more human that is
more community that is more local that
is more responsive and I think that that
is something that we should be thinking
about very much rather than having a
discourse which is about the elite which
is a category that is in fact to large
almost almost infinite to really the
same time it's a very concrete thing
there is a political elite this
financial elite we have people who are
running the media we have our public
intellectuals and under is a kind of
general sense to feel let down
by those elites because quote unquote do
i do is they are they are not accepting
their responsibility yes they come
together in the foes and they have the
Clinton Global Initiative or whatever
but what essentially comes out of it so
listen and I do think this doctor is at
least after smiley there is something
with this ruling class which which makes
that at least we we probably know now
have no idea what what kind of road to
take but I mean you have a sense people
are ignoring that ruling class you you
are hoping for a challenge and
confrontation to that ruling class
rather than witnessing the reality how
can we you can go to evolution of people
simply saying forget Washington forget
those things we will do it our own way
that that explains things like the rise
of community banking microcredit and
other phenomenon all over the world
those that have been ignored by elites
or simply subjects of elites are finding
their own ways to self-govern not only
not always good ways i give you the
states that have let the tea party take
over their state governments yeah by the
i think there isn't a kind of illusion
that we tend to have that gives me the
elites that are undoubtedly real know
what they're doing and I think for
example the examples that Rory gate
which are based in his case on direct
personal experience in Afghanistan apply
to some extent in the very different
conditions of Europe at the moment the
idea that by squeezing the countries of
Europe in at the moment principally the
southern countries but soon the
Netherlands and northern Europe to cut
back in services to cut back in pensions
to cut back in all kinds of things
including in Greece for example
anti-malarial sprays have become too
expensive
it said it's essential to the future of
probity and solidarity of Europe that
they stopped so that malaria will creep
back into urban Greece these fantasies
as it were are genuine that say it's not
the case that the people who have spent
all this money in Iraq and Afghanistan
and then in Libya and soon perhaps in
Syria it's not the case that there is
some cynical Machiavellian diabolical
plot behind it it's the case that
they're genuinely enslaved by a vision
of the future and that's my reason at
any rate for having my doubts about the
capacity of the current elites to
resolve these problems because what
these problems challenge is a vision of
the future which is deeply entrenched in
their thinking a vision in which they
play a central role with the ideas and
beliefs that they have and to strip them
of this leaves them almost deranged so
they're not going to do it they're going
to press on in Europe to the bitter end
in Afghanistan I don't know I'm not an
expert eventually there will be a semi
withdrawal probably not complete because
the amount of money the financial
difficulties in the United States the
unpopularity of the war in the United
States etc will force a kind of retreat
of some sort but it won't be because the
absurdity of the policies has been
understood any more than in Europe it'll
be because the absurdity of the policies
has been understood either and here is
my kind of key point I think here I
differ profoundly from the idea that
what's really creative about political
life or human life is attempting the
impossible I mean there is a kind of
idea going you know which has been
expressed here but it's very common idea
which is that what is distinctive about
the modern world is this ability to
challenge possibility and attend things
which are impossibility to produce
events that are not possible well not
exactly it seems to me what was
attempted in Iraq it was exactly what is
being attempted in in in Afghanistan
it's exactly what was attempted in the
early pier in in the Soviet Union and
actually
the world as it is with all of its
Horrors it's partly a product of these
impossible attempts of course seems to
me better than the original conceptions
in many in many in many cases because
they involve the destruction of so much
obviously there's a lot wrong with
traditional Afghan culture which was a
lot that we would object to and that i
would certainly regard us as wrong with
the idea that it can be restructured
reform transformed in it in a decade or
generation it's a complete fantasy so
the real question i have is this why is
this fantasy I'd given part of the
answer but I have to confess it still
puzzles me more deeply why is why is
this Francis he's so deeply rooted part
of the answer I think is that for many
people the fantasy that these that there
can be a transformation of whole
societies whole cultures can be
engineered by regime change or
technology or political revolution a
pure a Bolshevik Revolution a better
global revolution better more popularly
tribe distributed technologies as part
of this become part of the meaning of
their life they get the meaning of their
life from that and so to be deprived of
that plunges limit liberty kind of
despair so maybe that's something we
should start thinking about whether it
makes sense to invest the meaning of
one's life in impossible projects Rory
you you are as a member of parliament
inside the political world do you have
arguments why we why we should continue
our faith in in our political process or
well I think think the answer is that we
have a lot of reasons not to have faith
I mean I I think its writers as
professor Lau said that that there's
something very theatrical and peculiar
about modern parliamentary systems I
mean it's true as a British member of
parliament but one often feels that one
is the the priest of some dead religion
that the rituals that you're going
through no longer have any real meaning
I mean they once had a historical
meaning but but now they're somehow
evacuated of meaning and that it's just
a ritual and I think our it's true also
that we feel as we began become as
societies more educated as we know more
and more about our own particular
spheres we become more and more aware of
the way in which the elites don't we
become more and more disappointed by the
lack of knowledge and maybe the lack of
virtue the lack of coherence in our
elites but the reason I would say there
is a reason for hope is that there is
the possibility of a more productive
form of democratic politics and we can
see this a little bit in Britain I mean
the thing that is very striking about a
society and this would be true of
Holland to which makes us different from
a society of 56 years ago is simply that
we are just much healthier much more
educated much wealthier and the people
that I interact with on a day-to-day
basis in my constituency I can have a
very very serious engaged conversation
with I mean within their own spheres
they have extraordinary incites people
have very unusual or surprising things
to say about running a business or
working in the civil service department
or operating as a farmer which allow you
to get into a much more exciting
conversation about what's happening in
Afghanistan I mean they understand in
other words these problems of
abstraction isolation unscrupulous
optimism are is true of their managers
and their organizations as they are of
the elite internationally and one of the
things that cheers me up a little bit is
that in British politics members of
parliament are being forced to spend
more and more time in their
constituencies justifying themselves to
the constituents the age of these sort
of distant legislators is going I was
very shocked I was in Paris earlier this
week meeting some French public
intellectuals who were saying that there
is no need for a British politician to
worry about what the people think about
Europe
this is populism ignore them the point
about Europe is it is it's a vision of
solidarity it's a vision of Goethe and
Molly air and Shakespeare coming
together it's a it's a narrative of
globalization there is no alternative to
this general progression right I I felt
very very proud at that point to be a
modern politician I felt very proud to
be part of a conversation where I have
to justify myself to people where I
can't afford to simply talk generally
about solidarity and Goethe and Molly
air where anything I say has to be
pushed through the medium of people in
my own constituency my inverters
understanding what on earth I'm talking
about and being able to relate to it and
the thing that we need to change is how
to tap that energy how to deal with the
fact that in this room is as much energy
as much brains as in any room in
Republican Athens and yet nothing's
coming of it in the same way we haven't
created the structures to unleash that
energy we live very disappointed
disappointing lives and one thing I
think we need to do is to make people
move from the a political sphere where
all their energies are going into their
family or into that charity work or or
into their business back into the
political sphere and at that point you
get better elites you get better
politicians when you get a better public
we need to be a better public